wer kann kanzler oder wer es kanzlerin
eine der fragen nach dem trio vor den
nächsten tagen an professor andrea
römmele politikwissenschaftlerin der
hertie school of governance guten abend
frau professor müller
guck mal eine sekunde zurück gab es für
sie einen klaren sieger die umfragen
sehen insinuieren das ja
ja jeder hat seine strategie gehabt ich
denke die strategie von olaf scholz als
ruhiger besonnener staatsmann
aufzutreten ist aufgegangen armin
laschet hat das musste er auch auf
angriff gespielt da ist die rechnung
nicht so ganz aufgegangen wenn man die
umfragen an schaut frau berg hat die
rolle der opposition
eingenommen war frisch sie war mutig das
war nicht unbedingt zu erwarten weil sie
ja relativ angeschlagen auch in dieses
duell ging hat sich aber wacker
geschlagen wir fokussieren uns jetzt mal
ein bisschen auf laschet denn der ist
derjenige der wahrscheinlich einer der
schwierigsten position erst mit den
geringen umfragewerten und er muss sehen
dass er jetzt wieder vor allen dingen
erst mal auch die eigene mannschaft
hinter sich wenn die eigene
stammwählerschaft oder hat er da jetzt
ein anderer aufschlag den guten gemacht
wenn man sich sein schlussplädoyer
anhört noch einmal dass er gestern abend
gehalten hat dann war das ganz klar die
ansprache des kernwähler klientel an die
er sich gerichtet hat er muss jetzt auch
versuchen die partei zu einen die partei
die für ihn wahlkampf machen muss die
die wählerinnen und wähler mobilisieren
muss insofern ist der ansatz jetzt den
wahlkampf auf mehrere auf breitere
schultern zu verteilen durchaus richtig
aber er muss auch versuchen einen moment
um das gerade gegen ihn läuft und zwar
gehörig gegen ihn läuft versuchen wieder
umzudrehen in weniger als vier wochen
und olaf scholz haben was ja eigentlich
gar nichts machen der fährt ja sehr
gutem wetter dass er
wie zum beispiel markus söder etwas
sauertöpfisch gesagt hat die angela
merkel kopie als erbschleicherei bedient
ja er trat sehr ruhig auch sehr besonnen
auf gestern er weiß dass die wählerinnen
und wähler mehr denn je in der krise
führung führungsstärke wollen und er
punktet eben mit seiner
regierungserfahrung die er auch immer
wieder in die waagschale gestern
geworfen hat insofern ist das eine
strategie die aufzugehen scheint obwohl
olaf scholz nicht unbedingt von seiner
partei so 1 das heißt also wir sehen
olaf scholz und die spd halten sich ja
alle sehr vornehm im hintergrund
er hat da haben sie recht halten sich
alle sehr vornehm im hintergrund aber es
scheint eine einigkeit da zu sein man
hört niemanden der sich jetzt gegen
scholz stellt das ist etwas was man von
der spd nicht unbedingt gewohnt ist olaf
scholz hat vor wenigen tagen auch seiner
parteivorsitzenden eine kleine brücke
gebaut und sagte auch im hinblick auf
die einheit der partei er könnte sich in
einer regierung durchaus auch eine
saskia esken vorstellen aber jetzt muss
das ganze erstmal über die ziellinie
gebracht werden und dann sieht man
weiter
da läuft ja anscheinend vielen dingen
auf die grünen auch zu wir haben es eben
schon gesagt annalena baerbock kam mit
einer frische rüber sind die
diskussionen der vergangenen woche
passieren kann sich jetzt unbelastet den
restlichen die restlichen vier
wahlkampfwochen bestreiten also
unbelastet glaube ich nicht diese themen
die hängen ihr einfach nach aber ich
glaube es war ganz wichtig dass jetzt
wieder mutig und nach vorne gerichtet in
den wahlkampf gehen wird einen mutlosen
war ein mutloser wahlkampf wäre nicht
gut gewesen und hätte den grünen noch
mal das ein oder andere prozentpünktchen
gekostet sie hat sich gestern wieder
zurück ins rennen gebracht als dritte
kandidatin sorgt nicht es wahrgenommen
und jetzt wie gesagt es stehen hier noch
weitere duelle diese duelle sind oder
tree entschuldigung trelle muss man eher
sagen diese teile sind ja durchaus auch
ein format in dem sich noch
unentschlossene wählerinnen und wähler
in sehr kurzer zeit in einem kompakten
format einen eindruck der drei
spitzenkandidaten
und ihrem programm machen können also da
ist durchaus auch noch ein bisschen luft
nach oben drin also da ist musik drin
was interessiert denn eigentlich die
wähler das worüber wird heute auch wir
journalisten besonders diskutieren über
mögliche koalitionsoptionen interessiert
weder das was denken sie
die wählerinnen und wähler wollen vor
allem eine
problemlösungskompetenz sehen sie wollen
sehen dass die kandidatin der kandidat
die probleme die anstehen mit denen wir
konfrontiert sind lösen können dass es
hier lösungsvorschläge gibt da sind
natürlich die ist natürlich die
inhaltliche antwort ganz zentral aber da
sind wie wir in der politikwissenschaft
sagen auch die unpolitischen
eigenschaften eines kandidaten bzw einer
kandidatin wichtig wie gibt er oder sie
sich im trevi konnte sie oder er fragen
all das sind dinge auf die die
wählerinnen und wähler durchaus schauen
also emotionen ist auch darin nicht nur
thema und zwar wahrscheinlich ziemlich
viel wir gucken was oft rielle erstmal
vielen dank für den blick nach hinten
und auch nach vorne hinaus professor
andrea heumann guten abend nach mannheim